what's the weirdest thing you've found
yourself doing in quarantine because I
have found myself doing some incredibly
odd things I never would have done but
there's just you know sometimes let me
tell you I mean yeah the time is is it's
weird when you're in quarantine
luckily I'm writing a memoir so that's
really occupied a good portion of my
time which has been fun to go back over
your life I wish everybody can do this
not that you would have to publish it
I've never told anybody this I've
literally been writing mine like
separately because I was like this is
such a crazy story you're totally right
you kind of get to go back through your
life isn't that the best cuz you get to
live again it's the best and then you're
also like you just hopefully you're
wiser you know now and you look back and
you're like God that seems I know no
different then and why getting outside
the bubble oh my god the idea that I
used to I there was one time I was
thinking of writing the story of the day
where I I was hitchhiking to kiss and it
was like you know I had no idea how I
was gonna get there I had no idea how I
was gonna get home but I had taken a
tickets to kiss and I had and I had to
get there I don't know how just
hitchhike to put my thumb out and then
some some random guy I'm special but
okay you know I had the platform shoes
on I was ready to rock like even me
moving I'll tell ya I know I D I know
job I'd know where to live I'm but I
just went I was just like it's just you
know have to do it there's something to
being young and dumb I notice have you
thought about it be like what you did
what I would never let my children
[Laughter]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe my channel ease don't make me
keep going